all right for people joining this live
stream we are talking about some things
to do with the resource system which
powers things like the data repository
and bob was about to explain what this
is right so we implemented a resource
search 11 0 or 11 1 and since then we've
had a bunch of other search functions
come to the language and resource search
sort of grew out of consistency with
them so this is an overhaul of the
design to get it more consistent do we
have people here who represent text
search well Sushma is piaying the
general effort of consistency ok here
one solution was here yes ok ok
okay I'm by the way Bob you have a lot
of background noise a lot of a whooshing
noise very loud um
okay so do you have examples here can we
see it run yeah it takes 12 to run now I
get it
um I'm not sure what the best thing is
about wide anus and outputs and dock
pages that get cut off here well that
look all right in the belt no idea not a
question for me I don't know I I would
pick an example that doesn't produce
this giant output that's that's the old
one I just left in there so there won't
be empty examples in the bill so we'll
remove the eleven three outputs once we
approve this design wait a minute what
are the 1200 outputs everything this
tentative is 12 oh that one single
example that's in the middle your screen
right now is oh I see I see I see okay
fine so intimate so the point here is to
return not a list of resource objects
but for resource search to return a
dataset is that correct yes by default
the second argument you can tell it what
you want and you so you can get a list
of objects if you prefer that or a list
of metadata associations or whatever
other sort of thing you might want the
property field which is consistent with
web search and web in research okay
that's good and the first argument now
instead of just taking a string takes
all the specs from tech search so search
query string you know exact order
whatever fixed order whatever it's
called you know those those things okay
but so to understand I mean the backend
of this is the same as text search yes
yes we had it so basically it'll run two
text searches one locally and one in the
resources and back-end and it will
combine the results
here's a deficient if the search index
locally already exists and is efficient
if it doesn't it has to build it on
demand and then it's bad okay that's no
good right so why would the search of
why would the local search index not
exist so in other words that's a case
where you've downloaded lots of
resources locally why are you bothering
to search anything locally how could you
possibly have anything locally that you
don't have if you created it yourself
what's the definition notebook for
example and you never sinned okay so but
those so those are the only ones that
you're looking at there right actually I
do include the cached versions of what I
think that's a mistake
because I think you're right right yeah
you're right already pre-built sorry
this is the first time I thought about
it you're right okay um so
okay so if it does have to UM if it does
have to reenacts is it going to show
real eggs and string to it all straight
off your progress indicator yeah okay
fine so you know what's going on what
what is what is its text for what it
says uh building local search index I
think something all right I mean this
seems like a very straightforward
discussion I think this is all good
my screen is flashing which might
suggest that a version 12 is installing
itself
you
hmm the bad sign that my screen is
flashing multiple times
you
okay I don't think there's much more to
say here this looks fine any other
questions
no do you have thoughts on what property
should be accepted that little table in
the middle there has what I have so far
it's just I made that up I don't know
that it's perfect
well what is it food for text search
what is it for text search I mean that's
the grammar okay the search result
object thing that sort of you know
lazily Sushma can you speak to this
please take certain subject no no no no
the properties by the way why is the end
missing her I do think we saw such coma
end should be supported there's a max
items option I see and and the default
is like ten or something wasn't it given
all this all fall down a bit okay it's
fine
okay properties text search source form
prop what are the properties for
blowing properties
following additional properties so
didn't you look at this I mean because
this is the place you need to go
obviously right well there's also web
search and web image search which seemed
like closer siblings what are the
properties that those those those have
dataset and thumbnail and says okay just
to give a recap to everyone when we did
the search consistency we wanted
everything to follow web search web
limit search and even text search is
supposed to follow that but then text
search currently gives search result
object which is which has a lazy way of
doing it and we wanted data set to also
have lazy implementation which we do not
have yet so we will make text search
consistent with all of these other
searches when we have so these other
search is what do they have a sense of
properties it's you know it's dependent
on the search like web image search
system nails nothing else is gonna have
something else necessarily okay looking
at text search I think I should change
what I have this objects here to
resource objects or just resource object
looks like we are wearing consistent in
plural or singular for those things
well I'm sorry where are you talking so
right now the bottom you screen your
snippets page titles hyperlinks if you
look at text search you have singular
things like object and Association so
there's an inconsistency yeah well we're
all probably wrong okay um by the way
this is the thing Sushma should follow
yeah the in allow adult content okay
there is a new option to word list which
is related to that and I don't think
it's consistent with that name and I
think we probably should try and induce
some consistency there that's an issue
for Allen okay
okay I'm being told that the 12 hours in
the dock um and see if that's really
true I see no evidence of it launching
no it's very slow but something is
launching and if I get this then
hopefully boy this is slow okay all
right lots of flashing oh wow that
hundred percent now doesn't have a
decimal point after it that's a piece of
progress okay so now if I say resource
search of cat'
what pack is that doing why isn't this
instantaneous actually I guess it
searches three things but it only does
two textures it also looks for things
that you've done cloud to play on if
you've created resources cloud to play
so does that deployed resources oh yeah
that was no good that was no good we
don't want to do that right why would we
what is it doing that look I don't have
any deployed resources so there's
nothing to search why did it take that
amount of time maybe it was Cloud
Connect
I know this is brand-new Colonel I don't
this one should only be doing you know
it already has the metadata from your
cloud and the locally knows which is
selected there I think that's probably
correct okay
if you do something like face it'll have
some neural nets and some data mixed
okay let's
look at what this is doing
why is it called data resource there no
that's wrong it just the data type is is
this the content type of the content
object is it that's I'm sorry the
resource object there if I look at the
resource object here and how do I even
get that resource object copy data to
clipboard okay resource object
oh that's snazzy okay Fred we made it
height string height so it'll look
better in the data set so the resource
type here is data is data or yeah we
know it says date resource right it very
weird
you call them data resources data like
initially if they're either one works
whenever you type it in you can type in
either one but you know if you search
for something like face you'll get a mix
of data in neural net
why is this so slow this is insanely
slow come on you got it you gotta
optimize this that's no good that speed
is no good
I mean no can break down the speed for
you if you yeah right please do that
speed is no good the text search in the
you know it's running in the cloud you
realize right yeah yeah yeah the tech
but that should be blindingly fast
right a standard index search texts
index search is very fast it's a really
a shame we don't have the people from
text search here that's sort of a wrong
thing and as Sushma wants to comment on
this no I don't know about tech search I
mean the implementation of tech search
we get MA
so the way it's implemented and on the
server side each repository has own
index so this is jointly two different
text searches I don't care they should
be really fast okay so I mean the other
thing we want to do probably in resource
search is it probably needs an option
that gives the list of where the I mean
or possible is in the system service
stuff that says where the indices are
for all the where it should be searching
right yeah I have a hidden option for
that if we want to put a design in I can
have that done in a day or in an hour
whatever we want to well what would that
option be though those are the those are
the locations that are true reflection
right so there there's an undocumented
location that strings search locations
where you can give things like local
cloud repository as strings and it works
right now but we don't ever
we've never brought up it designed it
might be the right time to do that right
now
so I say that again what would you know
a string option the name of the option
is search locations and it takes a list
where it can have the string local the
string cloud or the string well how does
that work for Texas it chooses which
indices text search uses you know way we
could do this initially is method
okay let's tell a method option for
resource search because I think it's a
little bit squiggly what's going on I'm
making sense sure I cuz websites that
thought it web search does because it
has to choose between different web
search providers for right now won't
always be the case for various reasons
um
you
okay so I would put a method option
there and for right now what I would do
is I would say resource search um
blah blah blah what did you call it
repository as a string is what I had
well what what do you mean that's that's
that's what I have for search locations
sorry I search locations um know what we
should say is index locations are they
the index locations of are they these
their names like cloud and local I don't
Matt they're not place that is similar
to persistence locations right it is
similar to persistence locations yeah
it's much easier than asking people for
a file path or yeah sure and I already
know where these things are so it's
stupid for them to tell me where there
um what's the right name here
[Music]
well what is it called inside content
object when it's a remote location for
the content object
do you understand my question yeah I'm
looking at the dock page for content
object right now location
with reference alliteration reference
location is
I don't know about the difference
between those this actually
you
I think we should call it locations and
just have a list of those strings method
arrow locations blah blah blah that's a
pretty detailed thing but come yeah user
Kim can make there right okay so now did
somebody get Linda ghost look while Alex
went to find him I'll check
do we want to call the location for the
central resource system to be Wolfram
repository and then if we expand to
other locations we can put the actual
well why don't we just call it Wolfram
cloud I'll be hat well you could cloud
to play things too right
we have dollar resource system based so
we could call it resource system and
that would default to ours
or would default to the base which out
yet - whatever yeah I think it would be
switch you know everyone in the world
current right now has that value so and
if you wanted to add a different base
you just added as a the URL as a string
but now I think so but I mean what
obviously need is a resource system
pause in the end yeah
you know that's the name that we should
have here is a essentially search path
you
I think the other makes sense actually
the name we should have is even simpler
than that it's just path
and paths
yeah that's the right name
you
still underneath method though I'm not
sure
I mean we could introduce this okay for
now let's let's leave it there okay and
that will obviously be the order as well
and which it will try things
make sense yeah locations for right now
with the intention that we move to
calling it path when we have a better
way to specify if you don't also give
max items than the order isn't really
important okay
but the most important thing here is the
speed is wrong okay very very wrong
you know so we need to be able to break
down the different pieces and see where
they're coming from
McGavin I can yep I can profile all of
that
you
so on our livestream there's lots of
energy around the fact that the resource
system does not support things that are
tens of gigabytes in size
we're aware in order to do that usefully
we should be using MongoDB probably to
store these things because we can't
right now what the resource system does
is single gulp content objects right
they're all stored it could the content
object point to a MongoDB database or
not yeah the client would just need to
know how to yeah interface with it so
what do you mean by that so I mean we
could you know I don't think it I mean
with the data repository I'm not sure
why not
why not
just content objects right am I making
sense yeah yeah I'm not sure what we
came from they're having a thing that's
100 gigabytes in size because the whole
point is content objects have sub
reasons but are these is this can be a
database for controlling and
administering yeah it's MongoDB we have
our own MongoDB instance that's what the
MongoDB that's what the [ __ ] link does
my make enhance but yeah but it
generally when we've used that for
things like machine learning it's not
necessarily one giant monolithic think
it's you know a terabyte of 100 megabyte
items right no no no no you're not
understanding my point we have an
instance of that right so we can access
that instance clearly if somebody says I
want the whole thing right and it's 20
terabytes they're gonna be waiting a
while
am I making sense yes okay and in fact
the whole thing will not really work but
if what they want to do is to extract
pieces
then it will work fine
right to say get me the whole thing
depending on how big it is you know it
might be something that you can load it
might be something you cannot load I
mean the issue I guess is there's two
problems one is to store a bigger data
set in MongoDB where you can basically
retrieve sub parts of that data set that
might be you know hundred megabytes in
size or something right
so like get all the pictures of
ostrich's from the data set right what
I'm saying that you should be able to do
now if you say I want the whole data set
well it's very big and it may take a
long time to download and the only
correct way to download in that scenario
is probably to have a MongoDB running on
your data on your computer and that's a
different and more exotic thing right
I'm just saying there's this whole layer
of you know saying just ostriches that
has to be taught to the client free
would you go for each you know a set of
data no no that's not right that's not
right because the fact is there's a in
you know we just have to have a standard
way in the tum
you
okay so the question is could we back
some resource objects are with MongoDB
that's the question here yeah we could
okay so what do you type it what's the
top level design for saying just give me
ostriches
well I assume that it's the resource
object it is
in Welker that's a good question I mean
in the resource object we know how to do
it in resource data it's less clear how
to do it
right in the resource object we have the
you know that that was my point
so for each for each one of these
resource objects will need oh really
to document this whole query language
that's you know consistent but the
values are specific to the resource
right I agree I that's that's the hard
part case I mean what we should do is we
should look at for machine learning
training sets for example what's the
useful thing to do and if the answer is
are you going to have the whole data set
well then it's a question of file size
okay and let's talk about that for a
second what prevents us from having a
gigabyte sized thing in the resource
system
it's it's we have we have a couple we
have a couple neuron that center that
big better so when those download just
as a file download right yes and then
subsequent access to them works however
it works but the the issue here is that
what you want to do ultimately is an out
of core net train against this large
data set right so I think that's the
plumbing which we haven't figured out if
any right certainly internally we
absolutely do that we use out of core
data sets to do training right right so
the question is how do we provide that
for users through the resource system
right so do we know an answer to that
I mean if it's specific to training I
mean we could put in the data repository
but it almost sounds like its own type
of resource well perhaps that's true
okay so listen listen I think it's a
good point let us have a discussion can
you have a discussion with Sebastian and
Megan and so on about the neural net
repository and about training sets and
what is really needed from them get what
I'm saying yes sure okay all right so
let's come back to this um question our
livestream about about searching by
content type will be useful I agree can
that be done let's take a look so if I
want to do faces which are neuron that's
how would I do that face which is on an
11-3 we already had you would just say
neural net goes to face but in 12 since
we're going to be consistent with text
search you would have a list and then it
would say resource type goes to neural
net
hi this Nicholas hello
okay and then you could just have comma
face it's not doesn't need to be a rule
right I think the comment might be about
the the content type specific data what
the heck is that
I know something went wrong here
what was the comment okay this is an
uninterruptible failure it looks like
looks like it's something out of text
search well maybe maybe 12 hours there's
a bug on text search after joke though
track it down um okay so the question
for Nicholas
what was the question for that girls
here speeds that was the first question
yeah but so
you
it should be the case that calling the
cloud for a text search index query is
very fast right Nicholas
prowling the cloud no no cool legs of
calling calling yes
cloud right I don't know I know I don't
know about they call in the clouds part
but success itself pretty fast okay what
we gonna track this down guys so yeah
I'm gonna profile it and sadly it's too
neck terrible lead to neck if it doesn't
okay alright okay fine but then then the
so what are the different cases places
you're looking you're looking in the
central repository you're looking in
deployed cloud objects you're looking in
local cloud object local local objects
is that right rather than all staring
nope okay so each of those if you have
to look once so every time you look
presumably you run you create an index
is that a true statement or not you
create one index for it for the cloud
objects I'll create a new index each
kernel session for the local objects it
persists obviously okay why are you
creating a new index for each kernel
session that seems wrong all you have to
do is do an update because the update
system knows how to look at file dates
I'm creating content objects from the
cloud object metadata I saw I retrieve
all the metadata for those cloud objects
that are deployed which already have
store in one place I create content
objects from those to create a search
index if that seems wrong you shouldn't
be doing that every session sorry what
are you talking about these errors area
no because I know what these errors are
okay from not talking about that we're
talking about okay so listen to what we
are talking about okay we're talking
about right now Nick is sorry not Nick
Bob is is
creating a new index for cloud objects
that are deployed resources okay he's a
creating a new index for every session
and this seems completely crazy to me
okay
so what should be happening is there
should be an index created from people's
cloud objects in fact I I don't know
Nicholas what's happening for people
doing a search for their cloud objects
there's a P I I think I think Carlo did
that and this search from the wells in
the cloud no you're not answering the
question I mean so what I'm saying is in
okay okay
the the question is I have however many
hundreds thousands whatever it is of
cloud objects in my account right there
mostly no wait
okay how can I do a search for the word
ostrich in all of those notebooks
I don't know exactly how the clouds
anything works the cloud but so Sushma
that's for you because that's a that's
an application of text search that needs
to work right that's something Matt was
also supposed to I mean that's that's
part of the reason that map was pianning
the text search things because we know
we need text search for cloud objects in
somebody's cloud account right yes
Sushma I am NOT the pamphlet excess I'm
not sure somebody said you were what no
I am trying to make the search functions
consistent I I don't know details about
each of those functions okay all right
fine fine okay
well so this is an important thing for
Matt to deal with yeah so let's come
back now okay so Bob you cannot recreate
the index every session just totally
crazy so Nicolas it's my understanding
that search index update goes and looks
at file dates to figure out what files
need to be is that correct yes that's
correct okay so you should be running
search index update Bob that's exactly
right
okay why don't you doing that on the
cloud well I think what's gonna do that
in the cloud I know how to evaluate not
evaluate should I be running cloud
evaluated Shawn or should I be knowing
API to every users cloud account that it
does update search index
well how are you doing the update of the
search index right now when you say
resource search you say you are updating
the end you are recreating the index in
the cloud I'm not creating an index in
the cloud I am reviewing metadata from
the cloud and creating an in memory
index look oh that's crazy that's crazy
I mean this should be based
it's not because then you don't have to
call the cloud at all in a second time
but you have to call the cloud you have
to call the cloud every single time
because every time you're doing is such
in the in the main repository you're
calling the cloud you have to call the
API in the resource system but you don't
have to call you don't make a second
call to Europe for your own cloud
deployed resources each time ok I I
think this is wrong right I mean you
shouldn't be moving data because you
have no guarantee this is crazy you have
no guarantee if the user has 10,000
files right you're using moving metadata
about 10,000 files over to the client
side and that's just crazy right it's a
if they have cloud deployed 10,000
resource objects that's caress it will
not scale so that's good it's a bad idea
instead what should be happening is if
you really want to search the resources
that you are storing in the cloud you
should call the cloud to do it and it's
the same API call that you need to make
to the repository to touch it it's
really different thing no I know it's
not a different thing they both simply
have indices in the cloud they are going
through an API in the cloud and they're
doing that search right well one we
control the account with API the other
one are we gonna create API and users
accounts we don't have to create an API
as you say if we really want to do this
you know ok so first of all it is not
obvious to me that that
okay
okay the issue is this is a case so for
example text search right now does not
support searching users cloud objects
does it I don't think so okay right so
this is a new thing we haven't done
before where a a function potentially on
the desktop is searching your cloud
account right
yes Bob yes yes okay so the first case
of that is text search
I mean arguably arguably we should have
a thing called cloud search
which simply searches your cloud account
for some particular thing right if we
had that and this would tell it
obviously the way to do it I think
that's what we should plan on having and
I think you should for right now you can
even disable that capability here I
particularly have this method there with
respect and the default could not
include cloud
that's fine that's fine that would be
fine and you could use what the code you
already have if you choose to include
cloud right that makes sense I like them
but because I think that something is
going very wrong with that cloud thing
it's kind of crazy to move the metadata
over to the client-side if you if you
want to search each cloud user account
why not keeping an index per account yes
of course yes to work too much food for
that to work the best we will need to
have like a each file update should be
index L if you create a file then it
should be index L that's right maybe
right we can run CPU time every second
and everybody upgrade no no but then you
could do something like this
you could mark the file I have still T
somewhere yes this and this and this and
these need to be updated and the next
time you do a search you you trigger
some kind of update something like that
no that's good idea that's a perfectly
reasonable way to do it which is what of
course a place have seen this with just
modified so doing that all the time
maybe the same thing because you might
have a very large files and so you
really want to be able correct know that
you want to be able to either have the
cloud file system inform you this is the
list of files that need to be updated
and it could just accumulate that list
until the next time you call you know
search cloud search at which point it
will then go and you know do the update
and clear that list that's a reasonable
way to do it but okay so that that
realized so then the way we would do
this Bob's thing is it will be a sub
case of cloud search searching for a
particular directory but
Killer entries in a directory Gregg
Dunst everybody yep okay all right so
then then what we need to concentrate on
and that's the thing format is cloud
search and that's for Nicolas Nicolas
maybe you could try to prototype that
what actually what I just said the cloud
search which takes you know you want to
search for the word ostrich in cloud
files cloud search of ostrich would do
that that makes sense okay yes yeah you
know text search works on text files if
text search is the implementation thing
then are we pulling out the metadata
from each cloud jump into a text file
plus adding cloud objects that's where I
said search right yeah remember what we
talked about we have a pre-processing
step where we take every file whether
it's a notebook or whatever else we turn
it into text and then we run text search
on it right we talked about that about
skeleton files and so on remember is our
we can do that locally as well
what's that choice for text search I
mean we're not doing that for text
search now locally
what are we doing when you search a
notebook locally only x-files wait a
second wait a second Nicholas what are
we doing when you search a notebook when
you ask text search to index a notebook
it gets imported into plaintext okay so
it's fine
then that's the then that's the answer
Bobby there any further questions there
I didn't realize is that just because
text search the documentation says it
has a list of a brief list of files that
it filed types of it says it supports
yes McPherson has a list of occupations
it note that it can convert into plain
text and it does import on those have no
focus okay make sense okay all right
so cloudsearch do I have to make a note
of this can we make sure that
cloudsearch is discussed I guess in the
next text search meeting sushma could
you let Matt know that please I can pass
on the message Stephen um
actually I'm gonna make a note in my
central list of things like this that
should be being implemented hold on one
second
oh sorry just second um there's a good
function by the way and one that we've
needed for a while okay so now let's go
back to resource search so questions
from our live stream about searching for
things that are for example images
content types
but I think
no in 12 that'll be supportive just like
we have here there's a if you look at
the tentative cell the second tentative
cell it says what what fields are
supported and this well I see an extra
space there this will rely on the
upcoming resource type pages that we
need to create an documentation to fully
list all of those for each ruler where
is the remote so categories categories
is an example of one task type is one
for data and neural nets
content-type would be another one for
data right yeah now I understand why I
had an extra space I'll look at they'll
fix that okay um so yeah so that'll
depend on this that's you know a page
for neural that's a page for data that
lays out what those fields are okay okay
fine okay
possible response properties I wouldn't
call it response properties quite um
yeah just calling it a property seemed
weird
okay you want me to on tentative these
things okay um such as for resource
objects um this metadata too jargony
yeah it's awful it's garbage if I might
say so I mean what is it actually
searching is it searching so that we
have to be clear about this what it's
searching
so is it searching the what did we say
before
it still is just copy what it says here
why don't you just copy this cuz we're
getting rid of keywords we have this
we're using the check the thing from
text search okay give us a dataset right
nothing about when it's true okay of
resources and local and cloud okay so
it's just wrong what our resource
systems
you
well so what did you want to say here
I don't know you deleted it sorry
store it locally or well you know that's
not what you're saying what what you're
saying is this is I was sitting yes so I
was saying data set of resources whose
metadata include that which many matches
form right look at that look at that
usage for text search
okay that contain text matching form
seems right whose descriptions contain
text matching form but it's not just a
description what is it the details is
look at the third bullet point and
fourth bullet point down contains pretty
much all the metadata that's of the
resource object that's little why aren't
we searching the content of the resource
object as well we should be I mean in
other words if you search text search
doesn't work on no no no no no but we
can obviously export the content of the
resource object which is itself a data
set right we can obviously export that
to text so text search can work on it so
for example for a neural net for yeah a
some language function for well that's
what we have to do for each of these
cases right we have to see what we're
doing right for a neuron that if there
is a name of a layer or the name of a
port we could absolutely search for it
obviously we're not searching for the
innards of the you know weight matrix
right so similarly for data if there's a
you know a thousand rows of names of
different kinds of animals we should be
able to search for that
making sense yep so okay so separate
issue is to you know extract the content
from the datasets in you know data
repository for example yeah
it's yeah it's not a trivial project but
it should something we should work on
I would prefer to not document it for
version 12 that works yeah I understand
I understand
so okay all right
gosh so we have to write okay so um so
here we're saying
I don't particularly like that that you
know this is written that way because we
are we're vague about what it's actually
returning
yeah gives a dataset of resources
you
um
that contain text matching form
basically the point right yeah now this
[Music]
you
you
gives the property of the search results
of the results from searching for form
is the property prop
well that's not right I mean so what we
should say resource search searches the
or from
such as all Wolfram resource system do
you see their line two lines below air
type I think it's you're working on the
same thing
okay I agree that's right is that lying
about removing one is it next to okay
hey it's amazing how poorly I can read
um okay
I don't think that's really right and I
think we shouldn't say that
because we're going to change it
yeah I think we should say something I
don't think we should say anything
because it's wrong right now and we
should make it as bright as we can make
it
now these specific fields
okay what we need to do is we need to
say these are the specific fields right
so we're going to have content for
example as one of the fields
the content will be the the actual thing
extracted from the data set for example
yes so I think we need it a little bit
more detail here you can you can see
what roughly we'll want to do and
typical I think we should say
how do we do this and we can't do that
there but in text search we can do those
restrictions how do we say
you
actually wouldn't this be a better way
to say it returns the property prop for
each result
that's a better way to say it an item it
was a little bit okay all right okay so
here what we want to say where is the
arrowed form of this okay so what are we
doing with all of these this this table
should presumably be replace will be
repeated in resource search right
instead of just saying it supports also
farm so text search yes because we don't
do that because it's just a nuisance for
the user we might as well just say what
it does right that's the general I mean
we should we should repeat all of this
stuff here right yeah so people don't
have to go searching for another page
it's pointless but then what we need to
say when it says field here what kinds
of fields does this usually write that's
that's in there it's now the third no no
no no no where is it in text search
we have to define the index with tight
Westfield's in order to work their star
system you know then what we would say
here is his typical field supported
include
right yep
you
um and what about these why wouldn't it
have
these options as well content field
options and so on I haven't gotten that
to work maybe I'll follow up with Nick
on that you have tried but I got the
tortilla okay all right okay so let's
turn around that copy this stuff in
there add the stuff about what fields a
table of what a list of what fields are
supported with respect to this these
responses
well this isn't the same type of thing
at all
um
returns the property prop of these
search results
because it's actually a global thing if
we're going to say right serve a mix of
the two which is weird because you can
put things like name in there and it'll
just give you a list of names
but you can also have names yeah so if
you ask if you see a key there maybe we
should call it field
yes definitely ok hold on a second
possible properties of search results
you
you
you
include this
you
OOP
okay
No
data set including resource objects it's
that should not included well as the
name in the resource type and junk that
including okay what's a list of
associations so listen associations with
the name in the description in the
resource type and I can find that full
is gonna listen to associations giving
it's basically the rows of the data set
certainly properties of the real well
why are we why do we have it it's
consistent with WebP image search
okay giving certain properties of
resource objects
you
if we need to move on to another and the
the next segment of this meeting um
subjects let's put this the other way
around here
you
if this is how we're doing it but now
what's the valise
two fairies for
no that's a string right yeah okay list
of values for the specified field
you
as two associations containing values of
the split for the specified field giving
values for the specified fields
okay so this one is again something of
the form field one field two etc right
that's right okay okay
that's fine
okay so a little bit more to develop
here but to think this is in good shape
otherwise and probably the max items
filled my row is good no let's not do
that let's let's do this
resource search
you
supports the following
rather lame option okay because that's
going to but method in here for one
right now yes okay fine
you
you
okay so max items all that correct yes
you
advocates and other items to return ok
method so that should be automatic by
default I would assume where and how to
search for resources we'll save for now
now is there a resource the resource
system based is not an option it's just
dollar resource system based correct all
right it's also an option so why isn't
it is not a dollar ok so it should be in
here oh yeah
so
two dollar resource system base track
the base location of the global resource
system
correct yes I think we left it out
before because we didn't create pages
for that the simplest yet okay okay fine
well I'm not even sure those symbols are
right so they're not useful yet cuz
there's only one resource system base
worth using well okay so let's future
eyes that because I also don't think
it's right I think those should be a
pause I don't think they should be an
individual place and that's an issue for
Brad right yeah I could see that that
makes sense um okay okay are we ready to
move on to the next item
yes okay all right so I think we're done
with all of this we've had a bunch of
comments on the live stream about people
complaining about including Ethan black
86 who says I have many machine learning
dataset sitting on my laptop that I
would like to submit but the resource
submission notebook doesn't allow for
using file for out of core data comments
from folks here on that I'm not sure I
what he wants to do out of core well he
wants to specify file right you can do
that too what will happen well it just
copy it over as a file Oh will it try
and load it into core well if you
evaluate the cell it'll bring in the
core for the purpose of evaluating the
example section because you need the
data to make the examples work but when
you do submit it will just copy it
should just copy the file to the cloud
object it might but when you use the
thing in a desktop session it will load
the stuff from the file right yes yes
sir
so it sounds like um
uh fine well so that may be the answer
so we we plan to revisit the definition
notebook okay in a large way yes but
that's what we're trying to do that um
not for debt for data we're not doing
data today no we're not doing data for
today but we will do data in the future
since we're doing functions and so on
right now okay
so we're moving to the next segment of
this meeting um so people who were
involved with a search part could drop
out and what we're moving to is what are
we moving to this the submission the
definition notebook for the function
repository is that correct yes okay and
where do you have that material Steven I
just made you the agenda okay is there a
notebook for this it's not tricky Steven
it should be a notebook okay don't do
two keys
um okay well so the for the folks who
are involved only in the search part can
depart magnificent well from desktop
quit unexpectedly when I ran that
Packard update any comments Manu have
you tried it
okay well this this welcome desktop
quitting when I run quit the process
dies okay when I quit the kernel the
process dies that's been a repeated
problem for the last few weeks okay so I
don't know if that's been reported if
that's a known bug
does anybody know I don't know well so
I'm assuming how can I test whether the
plateaued update has happened pack that
information of string function resource
should be one point two point eight I
believe there yeah yep okay
so in it so there's yet a different
thing for function resource here is that
this is the latest development back yet
this is what should be in the 12 bill
tomorrow but there are changes we want
to get them all right fine okay so this
should create the function this will be
the new one now since you've started
back
okay
is that it that's it you know the header
design we just got a good knock up from
design this morning so let's take a look
at that design so that that is in the
definition notebook design thing here
let me take a look
ok so it's a it's a very lively Orange
then wake up we can call in and design
folks down ok ok ok
you
so
okay so the rest of the notebook is just
using default styles is that correct
well there's these message warnings and
I those more info buttons that have
inline style sheets okay the main fonts
and colors and stuff though
yeah default styles so that's so I mean
let's just see what happens just for fun
if I magnify this it looks just fine
okay although of course the header bar
doesn't magnify but that's just fine
um
okay I do think that should have an
information box as well there oh no we
can't have an information box yeah
youyou should have an information box
for this section at the top that
describes the camel casing and describes
what the one-line description should
have does that make sense or or is there
a separate page that is
or as the idea to have a separate page
for all that information
that was something I think we were
hoping to have be self documenting but
there will be a style guide page that we
can put that information on if we don't
want to put it here well so I'm assuming
that all those information things will
point to the will point to whatever that
central style guide is yes well we're
gonna have some of these I mean they'll
also have the information in the
notebook yourself but they could also
include a link to a style guide with you
have you started writing the style guide
no no okay
don't do that please come on don't do
that what do you want to do I want to
have something you either have to say
generically what it is don't give
something which is a specific right when
the other ones say things like keyword 1
and author name just say related object
right see here and give a couple you
know give maybe two examples or if you
want okay I guess related functions or
is this related other things it's
related resource objects okay okay then
then you know then say here name of the
resource object name of the resource
okay to cut what I'm saying because
right it should be genericized as
everything else is here yeah the
specific example yeah
okay um did the design folks join the
Jeremy or think I'm here yeah I don't
think he'll go is yet okay should we
wait for that I we can get going I think
at that time okay all right okay so
we're looking at the header bar
you
okay so this was saying so this is
active here
yes generate resource object and
documentation that's a little hard to
read isn't it but this over prints that
is that the right way to do this that
the that the first thing there
I think that's a platform dependent
thing because it appears underneath the
button on my machine okay you can work
on with them I think showing it under is
clearly a clearly better and by the way
the alignment is wrong here as you can
see generate yeah that's I just haven't
really touched it much since designer
stuff hmm so it's a little weird to have
these combo box ish things
okay resource object only
what
you
this is a shopkins respect out last week
no I remember
I remember I just didn't never seen one
in the flesh so what happens I just
pressed that button I say I get that
if I say that
you
what was this fear was it's as a
placeholder cat and still
I see what's this
because you've changed the default
placeholder content and didn't recognize
his placeholder content and tried to
find that resource object and it oh okay
that's fair enough
okay boy there are a number of moving
parts to look at here on there yeah you
haven't even hit open sample help again
there's another significant moving part
okay so I don't understand this is the
standard is this is the full size and
this is the full size so I don't quite
understand why this header looks so
different is that just a feature of the
fact you haven't applied the designs yet
yeah that that's that was just kind of
thrown together quickly to make it work
I copied stuff from other notebooks so
this now says deployed for this session
how are you gonna make that work in the
cloud I mean it's a cutesy thing but how
is it gonna work in the cloud do you
mean the the ribbon itself yep that's
what I mean set Excel they work in cloud
okay all right so this you can make that
work then yeah I don't know why not okay
okay function resources definition
notebook
okay open sample notebook style
guidelines terrific okay
do you think the word generators clear
enough here
build
maybe it should be bill
instead of generate comments it works
generate that build isn't too technical
you think I don't know yeah I maybe I've
just been in the biz too long
but notebooks say generate all right is
it worth saying see I find this really
confusing
it's intimidating that there's four
things to choose dress no that's not
what it concerns means it's not
understanding what an earth this is
you
could we say deploy no generate I just
generate resource object and
documentation with documentation and so
and to be a little help I mean do you
think we should reorder them just
resource object only and then resource
object and documentation just because I
think it's a little bit cognitively
easier to take the resource object first
I heard like that okay all right let's
do that at least
fine I think that will be enough okay we
ever need to write all this text right
lay the placeholder text here yes so did
you guys decide how to handle preview
yeah how it works like a cloud web
deployment we know I beat work preview
is the same thing as for this session
only with no documentation for a session
I think the last version you had had a
separate button and think the idea is to
combine that with this action it's just
a matter of letting people know they're
the same but you know whether or not we
need the word preview in there there's
no oh I see what we're
the last generation had dedicated
preview button we folded that into the
generate button here because it's
equivalent to just generating the thing
with documentation
you know I think we should just have a
button that says local preview because I
think that that is going to
I mean local preview for this session
why don't we just say before we get onto
the generator why don't we just say
local preview but getting an awful lot
of buttons here aren't we
well if we have a local preview button
and the idea is that it will pop up that
preview notebook without any deployment
locally or cloud then we could get rid
of the generate resource object and
documentation are we gonna do that if
there was a dedicated preview button
that would what about cloud deployment
oh I see because reading it deploying to
the cloud doesn't automatically open
that page are you thinking for
documentation have the preview be like a
mandatory intermediate step look if you
do want documentation you generate the
preview then from there you to play I
just think it's gonna be super useful
well look we can have a button that says
preview
okay I have a different idea here um
yeah on the livestream something's
commenting both documentation for custom
Packers is a difficult process for users
could this French to be adapted for
package authors yes that is the point
that is what we are doing here this is
the junior version of that um
okay so what I would propose is that we
have a different proposal so we have
preview and we have generate preview and
we have deploy okay and that those are
the only two buttons there's no generate
it just says preview and deploy and they
probably have icons as well okay under
preview and then we we have much longer
descriptions here so under preview the
way it works is um preview locally
and then
in my cloud account
you
something like that right on the desktop
seemed it could mean a couple things
okay all right all right
preview any any sort of preview that
involves the cloud is going to involve
deployment though you could see locally
in a notebook yeah okay locally in a
notebook
how about in a local notebook and in a
cloud notebook what is a cloud notebook
it's a notebook in the clammy I know
what I don't because I don't know it has
to do with this well I think the main
thing people want to preview if they're
planning to submit is that the shingle
page is gonna look like because that's
what it's gonna be presented on the
website but it's not okay well preview
in a local notebook on the cloud that
makes sense
okay so preview on the cloud is also
going to deploy it though that is
correct
I think that's okay
okay now deploy so the only thing is you
might be left with some detritus from a
deployed resource function that you
don't want anymore
that's right tough luck I think where
does it deploy to is in a subdirectory
yes it's fine
well yes these are doing anonymous cloud
objects right right the part that will
be picked up by resource searches in a
dedicated subdirectory but the result
it'll be well how do you know what the
cloud object that was that was deployed
to is here
well we have the results stripes right
now
which means this yes yeah if we do
preview on the cloud we could say
preview deploy to this location if
someone wanted to clean it up and at
least know it was there I gotta get rid
of it
that's a good idea
yep let's good idea okay so now deploy
so why not generate documentation
but we could lower okay all right
locally
so then we can just say resource object
deploy resource objectives
only I mean we can have a quite long
menu here with with separators in it if
we need to
okay
if you had resource object in the button
title you would need to repeat it to be
like deploy resource object and then it
could just say in this session only I
just see you repeating it six times you
know fine deploy resource object and do
we want it to me to play resource
function yes we do yeah this is good
okay so now we'll say in this session
only in this session only with
documentation
which shall be cleveland to the preview
in a local notebook I think so that
right it'll behave the same but it
shouldn't get the preview badge in that
case right yeah that's true well that
there's an interesting point there is
the preview notebook our version of
local documentation like are we gonna
store that notebook so I can ask no I
doubt for it to preview it's just a
preview so that I'm not sure I like this
deploy in session with documentation is
well yeah if you create one in session
with documentation then you run local
cache on that resource subject would be
I'll expect to build again that's real
later right then it's real
anybody know where I'm storing this it's
in repositories function repository yeah
if this deploy one is gonna be long I
think we could drop preview on the cloud
and just have all the cloud to play
Munir and then no no no no people want
preview people are gonna want preview in
that I mean look okay in the cloud
itself
I think both of those are useful but in
the
itself you probably just want preview on
the cloud you don't want in a local
notebook obviously
I'm saying if you're doing this from the
cloud
right
well
you know what we could do is we could
say preview in a notebook and on the
cloud and on the cloud means the shingle
page and in a notebook just means the
notebook version of this go what I'm
saying hopefully eventually those will
be the same
get what I'm saying yeah in a notebook
on the top yeah it's a little bit weird
but I mean it's pretty clear if you say
preview in a notebook it's gonna come up
locally okay so now here okay for this
session only
I don't think this one is worth having
in this session only with document I
think we want to say yeah think so
either
locally on this computer locally on this
computer paren with documentation
or should that be the default to do it
with documentation I can't see why you
would want to do it locally on the
computer without documentation very much
sure I'm still not clear on what the
with documentation means it means it's a
preview notebook that doesn't say
preview and it's stored along with the
resources the local cache great
you
okay people are saying on the livestream
that they want a package repository
believe me we are working on it it has a
bunch of additional complexity to this
this is useful as this is useful in its
own right and it is useful as a first
step towards the full package repository
it's coming
I won't even start enumerate in what
some of the issues are um
it's actually I mean part of it goes
through the Pacolet system which is nice
updating mechanisms etc etc etc etc etc
etc um
you
okay locally on this computer for my
cloud accountant publicly in the cloud
well I think we just say the same thing
for my cloud account
look let's skip this with documentation
from iCloud account and publicly in the
cloud what's wrong with just generating
the the documentation in this case it's
a little slower okay then okay all right
so then let's say in this session only
resource function only we could at the
bottom and list them and say without
documentation instead of saying resource
function only just imply that love to do
this I think that's okay and I think
that would go at the bottom like the top
options would be with documentation by
default okay fine
yeah I like that I think this is getting
good okay
okay um okay terrific
all right so now what's next - wait I
was thinking of repeating those options
again with the without documentation
option I don't think it's worth it okay
okay I think submit to repository I
think that's not a good symbol for that
I think that that is more you know one
of those one of our sort of temple of
learning type like we went back and
forth on that Jeremy had a couple other
proposals that yeah one was just kind of
a swoosh Hierro in just her inerrant on
the agenda okay I think it's a last link
you
I like that one okay yeah
that was my vote as well okay preview
notebook
it's not a definite it's not a
definition notebook it's a preview
function resource I think it should say
function resource slash you know and
then the word preview and big letters
right it's not a definition notebook
anymore
it's preview of the final thing and this
definitions have been made for this
session only is hardly in the title I
mean that's kind of a subtitle position
there and that's not the right thing to
the subtitle yeah rather a stripe okay
underneath here
look it should say function resource and
then it should say documentation preview
or should it just say preview
notebook preview notebook documentation
preview it's what I might suggest about
notebook preview look actually I just
think preview function resource and then
like a vertical bar and then a big
preview thing and the function yeah
makes sense yep okay so here edible
version is fine and then the next one is
the deploy function object that deploy
resource function and then it's the same
you know pull trap drop the very bottom
one that from the list you get before
you you've already done this yes yes
right exactly
contributed by I don't think the by
should be capitalized do we really
believe that if this is the styling that
that heading should have a period at the
end find topological boundary by the
river bar I don't think you should in
this style I don't think it should so we
have to change the style guidelines for
that mm-hmm I think there's a question
about whether we want this to be
repository branded since it's not yet
submitted so like whether we want it to
be orange because if you cloud deployed
it'll come up in the different color
scheme what different color scheme the
cloud color scheme black and red that we
use for just that cloud deployed
resources I would think that that was
the right thing for this as well though
we shouldn't orange it up well maybe
except that the the the definition
notebook was already oranged yeah was
implying that that's exactly where it's
headed it's just a matter of how far do
you carry that through in the black we
could make the submit button orange or
somehow theme that area of okay it's
just the definite
notebook you know with that coloration
implies that everything's headed towards
the repo yeah
I think we can leave this orange I think
orange is the color of the function of
function resources he says you know it's
it's orange this is orange
you know it's orange all the way yeah
and the the main unbranded is you know
if I've deployed a function and shared
it with you you should know it's my
deployed one and not from the central
repository but if it's something like
this then it's you know your local
documentation it's less critical to make
a difference yeah it's it's a preview of
the publication not of the deployment
okay this looks nice rest of that looks
nice
you
you
you
that looks fine what is the second one
is that a warning
I think the first one is the right one I
mean I think I know why we'd get a
warning
some of them would be warnings because
there's not really a reason to stop you
from creating the resource like when
you're just making your own there's some
stuff we would want to stop and well
okay so wait a minute so you need a
branch for that because if you're trying
to deploy this in some global way oh I
see you don't know if you're deploying
globally yet right so things like itll a
sea change do yeah it's pretty stupid to
let somebody deploy something that says
my function this the common case I think
is you open the sample notebook you
change a few things and your cloud to
play it not my function but whatever
sample content we have we want them to
be able to do that but you know all
right okay okay I mean I would then
there's also another than there would be
a little bit more insolence is it
different okay you know I mean you might
triangular eyes the warnings but still
keep them in read or something I don't
know I mean look the obvious thing to do
would be to have this be I don't know
whether this is to American oh it's an
international thing that to have this
peer stop sign you know an octagon and
the Spear warning sign a triangle if you
open up the next mock-up there's another
option for the warning and I think
that's what you've seen in the notebook
with the triangle off to the right yeah
you can see right there is sexual I
don't like it I like yeah I like the
better it's better anyway yeah I like it
significantly better how does Jeremy
feel about both red one um I think one
to settle I mean to me it doesn't really
say ones I mean maybe you can apply stop
sign means more but I feel like it's too
subtle like if you really want to
distinction there okay fine all right
fine fine fine fine fine then go is what
you have although make I would say
redden up the orange warnings a bit yeah
okay
okay employment stripes
there'll be a decent amount of click to
copy going on in here I think what is
this yeah I don't understand what's
going on here so any cloud apply you
might just want the cloud object or you
might just want to link to the cloud
object there's no income but it says
deployed for this session is that just a
mock up fake
oh yeah that's yes it's just a mock-up
issue it should say ok fine so the only
thing which bothers me a little bit
Jeremy is that it's not clear what the
grouping of these things is that the
this is the payload so to speak of that
yeah
I mean clearly if you if you emphasize
this line you'll you'll be able to get
that right
if you can't a bit of the sky penis is
making it worse though I think there's
maybe a different way to treat that no
no cuz they're both open at the same
time should we allow both it open it
once what do you mean both open well
you've got to opened at once you could
just only allow one open at a time maybe
I haven't seen that in notebook we do
that on the web
I don't think we can do that in a
notebook I think I think I mean I think
the question of whether it opens by
default at tell it's okay I what I would
do is just thicken up
yeah locking up that top line okay if
the I could make its open at a time no
but that only you can only do it locally
you can't do it in the cloud and that's
not good enough
all right so Rick stop forgetting about
the cloud okay you gotta think
everything you think you're gonna do how
is it gonna work in the cloud I think I
could make that work in the cloud till
it's not worth the trouble it's really
not worth the trouble it's probably a
very annoying feature it's just not
worth the toll by the time somebody has
18 deployments so long as this closes
what is the ex do anyway
okay and what does this do and that that
arrowy thing closes that closes that the
payload there that's right yeah so I
mean if you can close the ones above it
fine but don't make a big production out
of it
NU'EST on top I aren't really at the
bottom I think yeah I think so i
definitively think so
I think it's bizarre to do anything else
I arbitrarily thought at the top but yes
and and also what I would do is why
don't you left justify this whole thing
here I think it would look better like
the dropped
content yeah Jeremy you want to comment
on that I agree and I actually I think
the opener could go all the way left to
like a floating opener seems kind of
weird when it's you might as well stick
it to the left of the date I think if
it's left justified do you brought the
opener over there what maybe dropped it
a name from the date make it a little
smaller well we could put the date on
the right side yeah what do you think
about a date on the right I like that
fine I would believe the full date you
never know when that's oh yeah I did
that on Monday type thing is useful okay
so then the rest of this the phrase
deployed for the session I assume you
can get that from what we just did yes
yeah deployed or replace it with those
yeah for this session deployed locally
on this computer deployed deployed in my
cloud account
you
Sinemet no no no look deployed for this
session if you store this notebook it's
gonna say deployed for this session
which is kind of stupid
I'm saying because this session is no
longer by the time you're looking at
that notebook if it's saved yeah
temporarily deployed I don't know
temporarily deployed no because that
suggests it might be even more temporary
our deployed in the session
then deployed
locally
because not solely the same thing it's
not necessarily the same computer you
might send somebody this notebook and
it's like oh it's deployed on this
computer
go what I'm saying yes should I make it
something like Gray's out when the
session changes are you are being too
cutesy I think I mean it's cool if
that's the case deployed in the session
deploy I'm thinking about how like
messages now you can get like the stack
trace but if you just like copy like
message cells into new sessions or
whatever it's not going to give you
those options automatically
no don't worry about it
you
you
you
maybe those would that be okay
you
yeah okay
and they say function resource and they
give it and then the date
okay
that the visit webpage that's
documentation right
that the label for the yeah yeah we
should call it that I think
and that is not click to copy yes okay
it's the same URL is the cloud object
the cloud object will copy the cloud
object
but what is that cloud object that's the
like the shingle page and it represents
where the resource is deployed so if you
did resource function of that cloud
object it would work or you could visit
that cloud object in your browser and
you'd see the examples
but that's not true of the local object
right the local object does the local
object contain the documentation well
we're saying we'll start there but I'm
not sure how you retrieve it we don't
have a design for that would like using
the local object to get the
documentation directly you would have to
get the resource object and then ask for
the documentation
whereas the webpage you can just go to
it okay then first point is I think we
should say visit documentation page
or documentation visit documentation for
that last one
and then maybe we say cloud object and
then visit documentation I think
actually visit page might be okay I
don't think we have to say documentation
it's pretty obvious it's it's a I think
that would be enough to just say cloud
object and then say visit
by the way that should probably be a
lowercase o for cloud object
someone's asking what if the function
comes with custom math link or library
link code and the answer is what is the
answer to that for the function
repository right now I don't think we're
supporting it the function repository I
think that's you know people vest about
a package repository which we're saying
is no no I understand but if that
particular thing of being able to
support I think we are going to support
that in the end and the function
repository for single functions the
problem is there's additional complex
today okay so the issue is for a package
repository or a packet repository if you
just say oh you know here's all this
stuff it's a bunch of functions it's a
bunch of files and there's some
documentation which is just a bunch of
notebooks that's all fine but if you
wants it to be really structured you'll
end up with some system like a more
complicated version of this kind of
system if it doesn't matter you know if
you can have all kinds of things that
aren't necessarily documented all kinds
of external programs you run and so on
it's a slightly different thing but yes
we're working in that direction you are
you can do all that stuff with resource
functions basically any arbitrary code
you want to run assuming it's something
we're not going to reject because it's
just dangerous or whatever but so if you
have like create library or whatever as
long as you have all the necessary code
packaged as part of the definition that
does that there's no reason why it
shouldn't work but we're not going to
store a library and pass along with the
function right because that's what I'm
so you would you would need the
definitions of your code to be
cross-platform
if you I know but we have a mechanism
for that we tried a mechanism for 30
years for that yeah but so the only
issue there is it's a multi file
definition right right
so that's the only real issue is we
could support this if we could find a
way to deal with that multi file
dependency I would could support it even
in the function repository so long as we
could deal with the you know the system
ID directories
I think there are further caveat maybe
we could talk about another time okay
all right fine yeah I've done examples
where a resource function can install an
entire pack lid with style sheets
whatever oh really
it's definitely possible yeah that's
cool okay what else is there to figure
out here you've got endless messages
that tooltips and messages and so on
yeah well I'm just a tenant right those
have you review another day and the more
info content and the placeholder content
the sample content aunt there's a ton of
content okay
this this is one of yours now that's
supposed to make me happier well the one
knows it never for was why is that front
to lodge because we're not using tacky
tools stuff we're just using normal oh
why is it not just text what that's why
that was that fun oversized dad that was
my mistake
I can fix that okay I had it supports
rob22 your function I hope you don't
mind that's great I'm a big fan
yeah please didn't
by the way the glue the bluing of this
function name here is a bit unfortunate
and I think I don't know whether we want
to set the style sheet for these things
to not do that when you generate the
preview
that's all right it'll go away yeah I
think it's super useful in the actual
definition notebook okay well this is a
pretty reasonable definition notebook I
think
okay all right and
yeah and what does submit to repository
do it gives you a research submission or
it gives you a success object assuming
that it's filled out properly
there will be oh I think I do should be
capitalized okay so I we should stop
people from submitting the sample
contents that won't work we don't want a
hundred submissions of position largest
well we should just accept that one so
it'll just be rejected for a Duke lien
aim right away oh yeah that makes sense
too that solves the problem okay but but
so that's beautiful um so there's a new
workflow for a publisher stuff that
we'll be debuting with this as well
where we have these provisional
submissions okay that's nice but but I
actually think the submission ID um the
best thing to do will be to have a
status page for the submission and just
give them a URL and also I assume you're
gonna send me email am I going to have
got email yes Holly lovely yes so
there's what there's one email for the
professional case that one email further
in the queue case you probably got a
second since you already have a
publisher ID it probably still says data
repository - right I think now no it
says marketplace admin which is really
weird yeah that yeah that's email header
that this you call it resource system at
Wolfram calm yeah we whitetips thank you
for submitting data to the Wolfram
function repositories a little bit
Griffey that's probably an oversight on
that part
just do replace all on datato function
I'm sure it'll work out okay you've got
all kinds of issues in this text
okay so oops some reason that didn't
work
something very millennial about starting
off with her hello SEC good or bad don't
we want the light oh no um videos made
howdy yeah right that's random selection
of different greetings um thank you for
submitting
so that is that promotional one that is
the professional you need to get the
provisional our submission cannot
one-word be reviewed until your Wolfram
ideas approved to use a publisher ID
right so you got a provisional message
so you would have to go to that form and
fill it out okay
so what I think we should do
whether I think let's call it resource
team about that sounds spiffy um
okay yeah last time we looked into it it
was it wasn't trivial to change the from
field on cloudy mouse but it's not
trivial to change it come on that that's
obviously you should have a login you
know that that's based on that login you
can figure this out okay yeah we can
fear okay okay so I think what we should
do is provide these people with a Status
page for their submission okay so in
addition to the email rather than a
submission ID what are they gonna do
with a submission ID and by the way also
the submission ID absolutely should be
in in the subject line
you
it should say you know because that way
it'll it'll thread properly resource
submission okay so
number
whatever it was
that's what I would do
okay
all right I think we should wrap for
right now um Bradley you know how to
pick this up from my Dropbox so should I
send it to you yeah we can grab it okay
um all right well gosh this is
complicated well if we do the comfort
pretty complicated parts now then at
least users won't have to sort through
that well quite right and hopefully this
will be really easy for people to start
deploying these things and then once
we've debunked this we can just apply
the same things to the other
repositories yep okay okay great
I look forward to seeing more of us okay
thanks a lot thank you to people on the
livestream to see y'all soon